[Music]
you're listening to anxiety with Michael
Rosenbaum do you feel
that New Year's and Christmas and all
these holidays have hit you hard are you
feeling a little down a little blue yeah
how are you feeling Ryan yeah good I
mean it's a you know it's a new year
it's a new year why not look up I wrote
a resolution and I'm really going to try
to stick to things I tend to stick to
things for a couple of months and then
we kind of like slowly get out of it but
I really want to increase my diet not
increase my diet I wanna uh be healthier
I want to eat better and uh
you know I just want to feel it yeah I
think I think this year I'm starting to
feel better towards the end of the year
my anxiety's not as bad
um
so you know there's some good things
that happened in the end of last year so
I'm hoping this year is great for
everybody thank you for including me in
uh
you know your podcast world and you know
if I've said it before but like
last last episode of the day was John
Oates
a huge Hall notes fan if you didn't get
a chance to listen it you should listen
to it I know some people are like oh I
don't know that guess I'm not listening
but so many people come up to me and say
hey I learned so much about whatever or
his problem with this or how do so and
so dealt with their anxiety and I'm just
saying give the ones that you don't know
a chance because you might just be
surprised uh our handles to follow
inside of you which we appreciate if you
do are at inside of you pod on Twitter
inside of a podcast on Instagram and
Facebook there you go easy uh write a
review it really helps the podcast it's
a new year we gotta we need some uh more
listeners thank you to all my patrons
who stuck around and supporting the
podcast if you want to stick around
longer if you want to support us go to
patreon.com inside of you there's tons
of tears and things and fun things you
can do I write little notes I send
packages blah blah check it out for the
new year become a patron support the
podcast uh also you can go to the inside
of your online store we have great merch
and great Smallville merch that you know
is signed by by me that you know is real
because I I notice a lot of um
I notice a lot of people on eBay right
yeah I'm familiar with eBay yeah are you
I am hmm never bought anything but I'm
familiar with I have I have a lot of
these posters that I can autographed but
I noticed that there's a lot of stuff
signed by me and if there's any
discrepancy and you're like did he
really sign it is it and they overcharge
for things and
that's why on my side I said why don't I
just have autographs that they can get
that they know they're for me and
there's no discrepancy that's you know
so I don't know we've got lots of stuff
small the lunch boxes and what have you
um I will be with Tom Welling in Vegas
Vegas baby very excited about this uh
creation con with Jensen Ackles Jared
Padalecki I might even sing on Saturday
night with loud and Swain they're going
to be playing
um Tom and I will be signing we're doing
a Smallville nights on Friday the 13th
and uh it's gonna be great if you
haven't come to our event for for
Smallville nights it's a must everyone
really loves it we love it you get to
read scenes with us there's prizes I
recommend that uh we'll also be doing
other cons throughout the year so look
on our Instagrams at the Michael
Rosenbaum if you will
um at the Tom Welling or Tom Welling I
think it's at Tom Welling you can email
him at no
um what's your number one New Year's
resolution Ryan that you'd say you'd
like that you'd like to resolve oh
um jeez
that's tough will I stick with it I
don't know I'm gonna I'm gonna try to do
some more comedy in the new year because
I could I performed in December for the
first time in years and I would like to
keep doing that also you're writing now
you're really writing I I am trying to
do more of that and trying to do more
creative things that will make me feel
fulfilled and uh will bring me joy
that's beautiful that's did you listen
to that guys that's that's what it's all
about you know
creating joy for yourself fulfillment
passion
um that's a good way to put it creating
joy for myself yeah yeah I think we're a
lot of times we don't realize that we
are the creators of of joy of Our Own
uh happiness or whatever you want to
call it
um sometimes you know I I deal with
depression or anxiety you know I figure
out how am I going to do this I got on
certain meds that help me
uh uh exercising I'm hanging out with
friends
figure it out figure out what helps you
and you know better help is by the way a
big sponsor of us and I will shout them
out now because I I wasn't going to but
uh they've stuck with us for so long and
I think it's because of you guys people
are trying better help and I think
they're using it and they're liking it
and it's working
and that means a ton to me that it's
working I haven't heard any negative
things and I know Ryan you're still
doing it and uh go better help so uh uh
big episode today Steven and Mel is back
he always brings something
he always brings something and I love
him and I love that he comes in the
podcast he listens to the podcast he's
got a lot going on Heels season two we
talk about that we talk about uh Green
Arrow of course we talk about uh
you know just a lot of stuff you might
want to tune in let's get inside of
Stephen Amell it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
this is Stephen Amell and you are
listening to my fifth appearance on
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum I
think this is the most I've had with a
guest okay this beat sack Levi it beats
Welling beats Bobby Lee
um I think this is the most okay that
I've had on this is good and I haven't
talked to you in a while and I was
thinking God I don't even know what to
talk we've talked about everything but
we never could talk about everything
there's always something to talk about
there's always something to talk about
yes I'm except my life is not in
conflict or near catastrophe or I'm not
no I'm not on the B side of anything
really so no big major news
there's news all right we'll get to some
news first of all your legs look great
thank you I noticed you've been working
out more I've seen the the videos but
I've just noticed your girth thank you
you're you're swollen thank you in a
very healthy like yeah this is the best
shape I've ever seen you in this is the
best shape that I've ever been in
how do you feel really good no pain no
no I excuse me that's a little bit wrong
my left I'm dealing with some left
shoulder issues right now and the way
that I injured my shoulder was
being the lead of a wrestling show no no
it was throwing my daughter in a pool I
see you throw your effing daughter into
oceans into lakes into pools I mean
you're always like that's nice right
that's how you did it yeah except she's
a she's all she's about to be nine and
and I didn't I didn't warm up I don't
warm up to throw my kid in the pool no
we were we were out on the English
Countryside in Late July and I threw her
and I tore something I did something
tonight you felt it right away yeah I
think it's bursitis this is your
shoulder hurt every morning when you
wake up yes it does well we got to make
an adjustment here I've been told that
the cortisone shot will help
everybody has a guy but listen I've had
two friends go to this guy because they
had horrible shoulders yeah he three
guys one guy he just did an injection he
also did an injection on my shoulder and
for like a year and a half I I was
perfect yeah and then you might get
another one two of the other guys he
actually did surgery on and they've been
perfect for 10 years the guy's name is
Dr Neil godadra he's a stud okay listen
I'm in because I know that you have
dealt with neck and back oh yeah so your
your opinion on this means again I
promise you you're gonna thank me for
this this guy's wonderful done deal
cuddling with your wife
do you after all these years how long
have you been married 11 years it'll be
10 years this Christmas 10 years this
Christmas
do you still
do you cuddle because she likes it
yeah that's that's and she knows that
yeah she's like well you just cuddle me
like I'm gonna get how many minutes does
she need for a cuddle I can't cuddle
when you go to sleep at night
I can't I will start to flop sweat
immediately I I need to avoid any sort
of touching to actually go to sleep
right but smash cut to four o'clock in
the morning I'm a cuddle machine
once I'm into my sleep once I've gotten
my sleep going
I'll cuddle the [ __ ] out of her so wait
a minute you'll wake up rested and move
to her and hold her that's right that's
right she does she like that well I hate
yeah she does
look I never I'm just like I know I'm
I'm starting to fall asleep very very
when I'm not working I'm not falling
asleep very very early she is a night
owl but her golden hour her golden time
mine is hours before midnight hers is
time after 6 37 a.m in the morning right
seven till ten if she could pull that
off that is her she's in Bliss and I'll
I'll cuddle there she loves cuddling in
the morning the only thing that she
doesn't like is I have a tendency and I
do it out of love and you don't realize
that you're doing it I have a tendency
to wake her up just to let her know that
she can sleep in
and she'll come back and she'll say hey
I love you but you don't need to tell me
maybe just maybe just let me [ __ ]
wake up and realize that I got to sleep
and then thank you on the B side hey
sweetie what sweetie hey I just want you
to know yeah that you can you can sleep
in tonight today
would you [ __ ] off
that's nice though 10 years coming up
for anniversary and you're still
cuddling you still I see you guys I mean
we go to the same Tennis Club I know it
sounds a little uh pretentious but it's
not it's kind of like a regular Club
it's nice not that fancy it's an it's
it's a tennis club it's not as fancy as
it's not a Beverly Hills no no it's more
emblematic of the neighborhood that we
live in yeah it's just a place to play
some tennis to maybe swim to hang out
have some food bingo bingo I love Bingo
night
I love Bingo I'm gonna bring my friends
there to the next Bingo night I think
it's Pasta Italian and bingo I love
seeing you there you're playing tennis
with your wife you're doing things with
the wife do you feel like
you sort of have to do this because
you're gone so much filming and working
and focused and working out that you're
like we've got to do a couple things a
week to make the marriage work and be
healthy well I don't know if it's to a
couple of things a week to make the
marriage work and to keep things healthy
but we have really tried to
I wrapped the second season of heels on
the 1st of July and this is my first
stretch of time since
since I started on Arrow which is coming
up on 10 years
it's my first stretch of time where I'm
in LA and there is no firm date that I'm
leaving and going back to something I'm
still under contract for heels I'm still
I you know very very confident that
there's going to be more of that to film
but what we are trying to do right now
is just embrace
spending time in LA
that's it Freedom just just enjoy being
here yeah you know everyone it's not
it's a little bit different than
a vacation or a Hiatus this is this is
it our kids in third grade she goes to
school right by our house our son is
almost five months I mean you were
filming heels I I didn't even know this
I never am online and I I don't know why
I mean it's all you're going to text me
hey I just want you to know that I I was
I was like holy [ __ ] you had a baby yeah
when you got Bowen was it emotional yeah
it was amazing it's one of the longest
one of the longest days of my entire
life I had been I've been in Atlanta on
a
Thursday I was filming and ended up with
bursitis you know what bursitis is I've
heard of it yeah a little Bursa sack
like on your shoulder and your elbow and
your knee and stuff like that and weight
training one of them bursts in my elbow
so I was on set that day my elbow really
started to hurt
and I went to dinner that night and the
kiddo wasn't due for two weeks
and I went to dinner that night my
elbows all swollen and red to the point
where when I got home I I had to go to
the
um I had to go to urgent care and then
they sent me to the emergency room
because it was infected inflamed
bursitis and so they had to give me IV
antibiotics and I didn't get home from
the emergency room until 4am and I had a
7 A.M flight from Atlanta to Seattle and
then I was connecting Seattle to Walla
Walla to go to our annual knocking Point
party
and so I don't sleep
and then I'm on the flight from Atlanta
Seattle one of the longest flights that
exists in the continental United States
and I love Delta but they had no [ __ ]
food so I'm just not I'm not enjoying
myself I can't sleep
right I don't want to I don't wanna I
don't wanna start diving into I want to
start diving into Jack and Diet Coke but
at 8 30 in the morning
and then uh connection in Seattle get to
Walla Walla
call Cassandra and she says
um hey look everything's fine but um
uh our surrogate has high blood pressure
and a little bit of hypertension so
she's being taken to Cedars and the
kiddos being delivered tonight and I
went oh okay all right okay okay okay
okay I immediately got on the phone with
the travel agent so I'm in Walla wall at
three o'clock in the afternoon and the
best flight option out was about an hour
north of Walla Walla out of Pasco and
Tri-Cities that was leaving at seven
connecting in Seattle and then on to LA
and for that flight to La I mean I got
the last ticket on the plane so I'm in
29e no Wi-fi no nothing I'm exhausted
and my phone blasts at 11 o'clock as we
are on initial approach and it's from
Cass going I'm gonna head to Cedars at
like one o'clock in the morning
I said great okay okay awesome and then
25 minutes later my phone buzzes again
and it's a photo of her with Bowen on
her chest
because it just happened so fast oh my
gosh her water didn't even break like it
happened real real fast so I landed call
her up I was everyone okay is healthy
yeah he's a little on the small side
because there's a premium he was just
just a little bit above six pounds
and I said okay because I bet you
there's no food there right now she's
like no there's not so I have to stop
then so I stopped at a Wendy's on the
way to Cedars and you got a burger and a
Frosty and then showed up and it was
super super emotional the the moment the
moment that I saw
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you
and who couldn't use a few better coping
skills to be able to handle all of
life's curveballs look
if you're thinking of giving you therapy
a try better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge better
help can help you be the best you
possible try it today if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
inside of you is brought to you by
rocket money what an amazing app Rocket
money has uh especially for those who
like you know we forget to cancel
subscriptions to things uh our personal
finance we're like you know disorganized
I mean look at me you could tell I'm the
kind of person that just can't get it
together and they made an app that can
help us all listen to this if your New
Year's goals are to manage your budget
better and save money you need rocket
money say goodbye to last year's
outdated disorganized methods of
managing your money and say hello to
Rocket money the better way to hack your
finances in 2023 rocket money formerly
known as true bill is a personal finance
app that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place
that's Ryan hmm I mean they're making
life tremendously easier I know I like
this service when uh I heard about it
the first time when it was a different
name but yeah it's still there and it's
still good because you know I don't even
look sometimes when I'm spending you
just pay bills you don't always look at
stuff and if you really did you'd see
like oh my gosh I've been paying for the
subscription that I don't even use for
months I've just blew hundreds of
dollars
and with rocket money
they they don't let that happen
uh over 80 percent of people have
subscriptions they forget about like
that streaming service you bought to
watch just one show on how many of us
have done that I just did it last night
or that free trial that you never even
used rocket money will quickly and
easily identify your subscriptions for
you so you can stop paying for the ones
you don't want rocket money makes
canceling subscriptions as easy as a
click of a button simply find the
subscription you don't want and press
cancel rocket money will cancel it for
you no more long hold times with
customer service or tedious emailing
back and forth over three million people
have used rocket money saving the
average person up to 720 a year
wow that's a lot of money that's pretty
it's a lot of money for most people
that's pretty good
stop throwing your money away cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com inside that's
rocketmoney.com
inside
rocketmoney.com slash inside
within three hours of him being born
I recognize that he's fundamentally
different than our daughter how so he is
she when she needed something she let
you know I remember our first night in
the hospital in Vancouver
just thinking to myself how in God's
name are we going to do this
and within about 90 minutes of being
around him I was like this he's gonna be
chill he's chill he's chill
they're they're just they're they're
just different you know he laughs he
likes to sit he likes to look out the
window he'll sit already with me and
watch
sports for 45 minutes so sit and watch
baseball he's four and a half months oh
you're already making him watch
wrestling no yes are you oh yeah do you
still watch a lot of wrestling I do but
you were spotted somewhere I read right
it's some I was doing magic that's right
I was just at Smackdown I was just at
Smackdown in Salt Lake City you love
this [ __ ] I do you've always loved
wrestling and now you're on a wrestling
show all right now I'm on a wrestling
show but now I get to go back through on
peacock and I get to go and watch all
the old Royal Rumbles with him I'm just
gonna take him through the 1980s and all
my favorite stuff who's your favorite
wrestler 80s of all time
Hulk Hogan you loved Hulk I did I know
it's not it's a sort of a popular answer
everyone retrospectively like it was
Jake the Snake Roberts not always the
giant well I liked Andre the Giant too
but I only knew him through the prism of
his him being a bad guy because him
him going around the territories and
being a good guy for all those years was
before my time so I didn't know right uh
do you are you is there any anxiety with
you wondering hey is is keel's gonna get
picked up for a third season uh you know
what am I gonna do what's next you get
that sort of feeling you have to be
doing something or you're just sort of
enjoying this moment I'm enjoying this
moment a lot right now actually to a
point where I don't know that I've ever
been as settled and comfy in my own skin
as I am at right at this right at this
particular moment I'm really enjoying it
there's a
I wouldn't say anxiety but uh we are
going through a process right now where
Stars was acquired by Lionsgate in 2016.
and they are now in the process of
as best I understand it untangling that
partnership I have no idea what that
means yeah by the way but again from the
little of it that I understand
as the as they are untangling everything
they are figuring out which assets
belong to whom so as a result we wrapped
filming on the first of July and we
don't have a premiere date let alone a
trailer let alone an indication of
season three
I know that I know that there are
meetings that are starting to happen
about writing for season three really
but in the normal in the normal order of
things we would have more information
than right it's been two months it's
been a couple of months three months
it's been three months and no Trail or
no so does that does that worry you have
you talked to Pete Siegel have you
talked I mean I just talked with Mike
O'Malley this morning who's our
showrunner and he's like I'm at it he's
like I'm putting the finishing touches
on eight which is our final episode this
year so again that's how far along we
are in the process
it's amazing I I'd be worried if I
thought that if I didn't think the
season was spectacular I think the
season's it's better than one 100 way
better more action
more story more scope more I'm
you know I I personally think that that
I went up a level for a variety of
reasons and I'm I'm incredibly happy
with my performance and and the action
and the storytelling and just the I
don't know it was just and it also felt
more like a cohesive season because we
actually shot it
in order and
you know we're subject to
covid hiccups but not coveted
catastrophes right yeah I mean I I got
it I got it again this year and it was
very fun it was very frustrating it was
a kind of a nice break though no you get
10 days off [ __ ] sucked I [ __ ]
hate you wanted to work no I hated it I
didn't like it no I wanted to I wanted
to work too like yeah I'm gonna watch
some movies also because we were trying
to we were trying to craft my schedule
around the forthcoming birth of our
kiddo so I didn't I wasn't asking for a
ton of time off I just sort of gave them
the window as to as to when it was going
to happen
and um
yes but then I ended up
having time off when I was supposed to
be working really hard so then working
really hard when I was supposed to be
having how do you feel about sex scenes
I love them I think they're great I
think they're hilarious
I think they're hilarious and I think
they're a bunch of fun that doesn't
don't people like sex
yeah but it's fake sex and you have to
kind of put on something what if you're
not attracted to someone you have to act
we can do the deductive logic on this
one I mean my show is my show my
character is married on the show to
Allison left's character so it was
likely with her let's say theoretically
she's a great kisser you know am I not
having a am I not having fun right her
husband's lovely too I think he's a
great guy and maybe it would be awkward
if he was standing on set like with a
scouring look on his face but he wasn't
he's not allowed it's closed set so I
think we're good to go all right so in a
way in a way I'm mostly I'm I'm mostly
I'm not actually kidding about them
being funny this is amazing this is
hilarious I think in a way it's good for
a marriage it's almost like you get a
little uh have a little fun on the side
that's just fake that you're getting
paid for that's worked they got their
lives you got your lives but you're
enjoying the moment you're like you know
what I I wasn't I'm not able to do that
in real life yeah listen I can I I agree
with that too it's gonna Goose the
marriage a little bit I'm know that Cass
when she was doing Roswell New Mexico uh
you know I had a couple of uh had a
couple at CW
um makeup scenes but you know I had to
kiss this guy and he was strong and
strapping and handsome I think he was on
Friday Night Lights at one point
oh is that what's his name uh Kitsch no
no
uh yeah no yeah
oh really oh yeah if I look Canadian
great body thank you I don't know why I
said thank you
no but I I was certainly when I knew
that those scenes were coming up or had
happened
I'm paying a little bit of extra
attention to Cassandra
excusing the marriage just a little bit
really just a little hey yucky we're all
competitive wow
that's amazing that's amazing your
perspective on it I
maybe it's just maybe I'm just the only
one being no I I always say it too
when I had opportunities like when I was
supposed to kiss Kristin crook you think
I was like oh [ __ ] oh man this sucks
what she probably just horrible breath
ugly in person not true not true perfect
breath perfect just a perfect she's an
awesome woman I think I love her I just
rediscussed this on the on the first
time that I was ever on the podcast I'm
sure but I did uh and she had a CW Show
in 2012 when Arrow was coming out I
think if she was I think it was
I think it was Beauty and the Beast and
we did some we did some press together
and she is just she is easily one of one
of the most beautiful people people yeah
come across I agree I mean lovely but
also just stunningly attractive stunning
and even see her as like an adult we
started work when she was probably 18
and now she's 40. and I'm seeing her
cons and we're hanging out I'm like
she's just awesome she's still awesome
she's growing up growing into a
beautiful and really intelligent woman
like a fine wine whereas me you and
Welling we're like old whiskey you know
you're like that's whiskey
yeah it's fine
um if if how disappointed would you be
if they didn't pick up heels or if
something happened like that would you
be would be devastating to you
that would be devastating because I
think you have any connection to this
show than you have with other shows it
would be devastating but I'm not I
wouldn't wallow
you wouldn't there would be more of a
disappointment because I feel like we
would have missed the mark
right the show's too good I I would have
gone I would have centered more around
and now I this sounds a little bit like
I'd be in denial because obviously
um you know a show is you know
principally carried by its performances
but there would be a part of me that
would be going how do we not how do we
how did we miss the mark like but then
again there are things that are there
are things that are out of my control I
can control the work the work is really
good the writing's really good the cast
is really good the vibe on the show is
really good the people who have seen the
show love it it's just a matter of have
enough people seen it not only that but
it could be like you know this is a big
cause to us could be you know there's an
expensive show could be there's a lot of
variables again that you can't control
cannot control but out of all the shows
that you've done the movies would this
be the biggest hurt to you if like it
didn't get picked up that would be like
you'd be like the most devastated as
opposed to when Arrow ended and all
these other things no I'd be totally
fine if Arrow had if that if the pilot
of Arrow hadn't been picked up to series
that would have been a tough one but
this this this this honestly this the
the work the work speeds for itself I
would yeah I'd be
certainly I'd be annoyed that's for sure
what would you do next what would be on
your mind what would you think of doing
I have absolutely no idea
I guess they'd send you out on projects
and look for projects for you no idea I
mean I guess if I guess if if the word
came down tomorrow
I guess I'd set my sights on pilot
season I don't know
but you always want to work there's not
not a part of you that wants to take a
couple years off and just I wanna I know
I want to work I want to work I'm very
happy and and settled in my own skin
right now and and feeling good I also
want to work do you think that will last
forever do you think how old do you
think you'll be before you throw it in
go to talent I don't know I I don't
think more than a I don't think more
than a year at a time your ability to
predict stuff
gets worse over time right it was one of
the reasons why I was listening to a to
a
I listen to a variety of podcasts from a
variety of sides of the spectrum but
this happened to be a Jordan Peterson
Joe Rogan podcast and he was talking
about how you know the predictions about
climate and the planet and this that the
other thing are just a lot of them are
so Preposterous because it just becomes
nearly impossible to predict things
when
when you factor in time right like
anyone that made an economic prediction
in 2019 were they anticipating the
global pandemic
no that fundamentally Alters everything
so any prediction that you made in
January of 2020
that had to do with 2030 it's [ __ ]
right let alone 2021.
right it's just I don't know it's just
numbers just it's just just yeah just
give me like give me give me a year at a
time I'm good for the remain I have made
my peace with the remainder of 2022.
and then I've got a job to kick off
I got a job a little thing to kick off
2023 and then I'll do that it it's a
it's a it's a job
it's a movie
it's a movie yeah
is it a cool movie is it exciting is it
a thriller is it action is it comedy
it's cool
I'm not going to talk about it you can't
talk about whether it's scary or it's
it's action I hope it's scary and I hope
there's a lot of action
and you have you would start filming
that in 2023. I started filming that at
some point and yeah at some point in
2023 and we have look heels is gonna
come out eventually right this season's
coming out it's coming out and you don't
know when though but the spot I would
anticipate the first quarter of 2023.
okay I'd be a first or second quarter of
2023 it was beyond that at and it's got
to be first quarter I bet it's going to
Premiere I would better be first quarter
and then code eight part two is going to
be effectively done and locked by the
end of this year code eight with your
brother yeah we did we filmed a second
one I didn't see the first one yet did
you not no react with your brother with
my cousin yeah well brother cousin
people think we're brothers yeah yeah
they always say it's your brother it's
that's fine just Robbie yeah we have the
same last name how do you like working
with him
it's good
it's good is it weird that your family
it is weird it gets it it we have and I
think that he would say that he would
say the same thing is we have different
we have a different process
um I wouldn't really know how to
describe our processes other than to say
looking from thirty thousand feet they
seem different so we will have the
occasional moment of
butting heads a little bit right
but I think that's kind of because it's
it's family like you don't know always
where to blur the line between this is a
professional environment and we're
cousins and I played with you when you
were in diapers
right you just don't just don't totally
know and occasionally you know he's
super easy going
I like a schedule
and so something rules off his back and
it hits me right in between the eyes
right right
it that's just that's just the nature of
working with is there a competitive
thing no not at all not that you're
aware of not that I'm aware of no and
and I don't I do not get that I do not
get that sense from him good at all you
want to make each other one of the one
of the one of the reasons that I look up
to him a lot I'm older but one of the
reasons why I look up to him a lot is
just because he
has the ability to
put a lot of passion into things but not
to take things too personally
right that's a good quality it's a
really great quality because you know
we're we're artists and when we're
slighted it's it's difficult for not to
feel
like it's a very personal thing it's
often not and more often than not in
fact nine times out of ten it has
nothing to do with us it's not personal
but we take it personal anyways and I
learned from him
no just just take a breath and
you know if you're on the right then
keep doing what you're doing and it'll
all come out in the wash so code eight
part two I think that's what it's going
to be called you filmed it yeah it's
done we filmed it last October November
December in Toronto
that's pretty sweet but it's a this
one's a big this one's a big Netflix
release really yeah the first one was
really a bet on ourselves
this one also in a different way we are
betting on ourselves I mean we took
we took some decent compensation but
anything that we took out wasn't going
on screen so
this movie was made for I think 20
million bucks wow and that's a that's a
big budget it is a big budget and I'd
like to think that
just that if it comes out and it does
the type of numbers that it did that the
first one did on Netflix the first one
did incredibly well which is why Netflix
you know took on the property it's not
typical for Netflix to make something a
Netflix film when the first one was not
on Netflix right but if we can perform
really well for them at 20 million bucks
then I feel like they're gonna want us
to make
four more of these things
that'll be pretty fun fine by me I want
to be a one of them that's
if you do three I gotta be in Cody part
three code eight part three I'm just
gonna go code nine code ten whatever
hey you know I think we talked about
this but not really but you weren't all
boys home for a while
from school and all boys school home
what do you mean a home oh boy's school
was that was that for was that a
disciplinary school was it a was it a
tough school it's a it was it's a just
happens to be a boys school I think that
they have a sister school now or they
opened up an all-girls school that's
close to the campus but no it's just it
was just where my dad went it was like
you know in in Toronto there's there's
uh rural St George's which is a boys
school I believe it might be co-ed now
there's Upper Canada College which is
still an all-boy school there's Saint
Andrews college and then there's stuff
like Ridley which is now Kodak co-ed
Trinity which is co-ed and um you know
they make up a network of independent
private schools in uh in Ontario or in
Canada were you a tough kid growing up
were you did you have size were you
um popular or did you get did you you
know what was it like growing up are you
difficult would your parents say it was
difficult raising Stephen I don't think
trouble I didn't get it no I didn't get
in trouble I mean I had my I didn't
really I didn't apply myself that well
it didn't have a lot of discipline no no
not at all you just want to have fun
just want to have fun just wanted to
play sports just wanted to and then when
it came to school I just I just wanted
to I just wanted to get by just move it
along I think that's what I did just
move it along I just wanted to get
through it but if there was stuff that I
was interested in I excelled yeah that's
that's how I yeah if it was a certain
subject that the teacher made it
interesting yeah and I just like the
teacher yeah and he had patience and
there was something about then I would
it was I would I would Excel English
um our uh Mr Staunton Ted Stanton taught
me AP American history I was infatuated
with with America's history I liked it
and so yeah so you know in that I would
you know that I got an A
but you know I can everything else
science I remember
I remember I went in my freshman year I
think and I had a chemistry class I
walked in it's like all right for the
first test you're gonna have to memorize
the periodic table and we're gonna have
the test on Tuesday and I walked out
walked down to the guidance couns or
something and got into General Science
yeah you got out of it I was like [ __ ]
this this is gonna be a [ __ ] I remember
on my 11th I swear to God never took
down the street gosh I think it was
grade 11
grade 11 biology
on the final exam I just wrote down I
have no intention of taking any more
biology classes in high school could you
please just give me a passing grade
and they did yeah give me he gave me he
gave me a 50 50 on the dog
I was in in college and um
I remember I was about to graduate and
Tom titino called me into his office and
Tom goes hey Michael I'm looking here
and I've noticed that in your major here
you don't have any dance classes as part
of your theater major or something like
that you're supposed to have these these
dance majors and I go
no no because you can't graduate unless
you've taken these classes I go not that
what that's not what the book read the
uh there was a book of like what you
need for requirements and I dug up the
book from 1989 when I was about to
graduate and sure enough in the thing it
was the only one it said it did not
mention your dance and so I got out of
it I squeaked by I always would squeak
by with things I was just like how do I
whether I cheated a little bit or I I
had this guy Dr uh Mr nordhorn in
algebra and I used to go up during a
test and I go yeah I just can't and he
would work the problem out with me and
give me the answer and I would keep
going up to him I don't know how I got
through school I never thought I would
get through grade school high school I
was terrified of everything I just
wanted to get through it a lot of people
enjoy things they have fun I think
that's carried with me do you are you
someone who really could enjoy things or
do you are you doom and gloom it doesn't
seem like you are that kind of guy seems
like you could just you're like hey I'm
gonna have fun I'm gonna go on set every
day I just don't want to get through it
well
yeah I'm I can just have fun and I can
really apply myself it also took me
28 years to figure out what that thing
was going to be
right like it took me 28 years why'd you
say that why because that's when I
settled on acting
and it makes me feel being on set
working on set makes me feel a way that
nothing else does professionally
that is what were you doing before 28 I
was acting a little bit but you know I
was getting committed to it you really
know this is what you're going to make
no I no I I I committed to the idea that
I wanted to be famous
I'm glad you admit that because there's
so many actors who come on here and I go
for me I gotta admit when I was a kid I
thought I want to be in the mood you
know a certain age I want to be in the
movies I want to be famous I want to
make money I want yeah that that's
exciting it is exciting I want to be an
actor no that was I mean I of course I
did I want to get better and I did
theater and I did classes and I got
better and better but deep down I really
did want to be famous 100 and it wasn't
until I abandoned that idea and just
decided look if that happens that's
great but I actually just I really enjoy
acting yeah like and you know one of the
reasons that I enjoy it is because I
enjoy watching television I enjoy
watching movies I enjoy thinking about
performances in the same way that I
enjoy talking about baseball and arguing
stats and watching football except I I'm
not good enough to be a pro basketball
player I'm not good enough to be a pro
baseball player I'm good enough to be a
professional actor like I get a chance
to do it so when I abandoned that and
just thought to myself I'm gonna I'm
gonna do this because it makes me happy
naturally
then a lot of the
superficial and materialistic things
that come with acting then come along
with it right and now I can say I'm
doing it for the love of it but
concurrently I can say that because I'm
very well compensated when I do it right
do you pinch yourself still are you able
to be grateful are you able to sit there
and take a smile and say look what I've
accomplished good for you did you ever
think we're gonna make it this far just
being good to yourself or do you not
really think about those things I don't
really think about those things
I will say that
that
getting done with arrow and moving away
from it and hopping off that
that the proverbial hamster wheel there
gave me a little bit more perspective
and I certainly I am I am very grateful
I love nothing more than I love nothing
more than than being on a on a film set
and
um you know being someone that comes in
comes prepared comes with a good
attitude but also brings a tries to
bring a professionalism that is
appreciated by the crew and the cast as
well you want to be respected and and
appreciated I want to be respected and I
want to be appreciated and I also want
to try to get people home to their
families at a reasonable hour that's a
good thing it is right and I'm not that
doesn't mean cutting corners
but you know there's there's a lot of
things that actors do not so much actors
that I work with on sets that I'm on
because I don't
because I for the majority of the time
over the past 10 years I'm the de facto
leads so you can't it if I'm behaving
one why you have to follow suit because
otherwise it otherwise it sticks out
right but
um you know a lot of things that actors
do on set and they're they're process
can um drive you crazy well it's
indulgent let's be honest it's a little
masturbatory you should be able to just
jump into it let's just do this let's
[ __ ] go there's two guys guys there's
always there's always take two that's
how I like come on that's what I like I
don't like to rehearse too much let's
get after it let's go let's go let's
shoot the rehearsal
shoot the rehearsal shoot the rehearsal
yeah let's go good things come out good
things come out um do you think you
still need be honest you always are
do you think you need a lot of external
validation do you like to hear Stephen
is great at this Stephen is good at this
is something you need is it something
you just it's nice to hear but I know
inside that my I I'm validated because I
respect myself and I know I'm doing a
good job it's a combination of both I
don't need it it's nice though
it is it is really nice
um when I'm not doing something at this
point like when I'm not promoting the
second season of heels or I'm not
promoting the second code eight
I like to
uh I like to disappear
I'm not looking to
I'm not looking to do or be you do
Disappear by anybody I like to disappear
but at a certain point
at a certain point the proverbial IMDb
star meter starts to creep down a little
bit and and you want that you you sh you
want it to you want it to pop back up
I'm happy to just hover around 2200
there it is I'm happy I'm always there
it's like hey he's not 40 000. no he's
not 800. you know there's there's been a
slightly there's been a slightly
humbling moment you know you and I we
both go to cons quite often and you know
when I go it is it's I'm always I'm
always
slammed you know with meeting people and
taking photos and stuff like that and
I'm still slammed I'm a little less
slammed than I was when Arrow was on the
course and so you just have to like you
know this is life you have to you have
to roll with the punches on this one I
mean the Smallville fandom is different
in different this day and age than it
was when the show was on the air yeah so
you just have you just have to accept
that if I had a problem with that maybe
I shouldn't have [ __ ] stopped the
show true speaking of which
if we've talked about this briefly but
like different in a different scenario
if someone called you from the
arrowverse which they call it now of
course I've always called it but if
someone called you and said hey we want
you to do a guest star come back as the
arrow for one of these shows just an
episode or two sure be honest would you
be like that's not what I want to do or
would you consider it oh it all depend
the storyline
this the storyline the money the less so
the money because you're not
you're not the star anymore of the show
well but also this is a this is this is
a one-off
right it would be you're going back for
for an episode or two episodes you're
not going back to recreate the show
right so you know the money
everyone's gonna haggle but you're not
gonna get an extra four million dollars
out of them you might know you might you
might get your quote or half your quote
or something sure but it it would more
it would more come down to
you know I like
I like going online and I like seeing
reaction videos right when fans see
something in a television show that they
like so I would think to myself as a fan
of whatever show
how pumped would I be if so-and-so
character just appeared so from that
from that angle I'd probably be like
yeah let's do it but again depends on
the depends on the show it really like I
know that this sounds like
keep in mind that I'm honest because I
said earlier that I got into acting
originally to be famous so so believe me
when I say that this really would come
down to the storyline sure
but I think that if anyone's listening
like what's his name creator of uh Arrow
a great Valencia Greg bellanti wanted to
forget his name he found his name in TV
if if he was listening or other
producers were listening and they go oh
it's not about the money we can get him
for a price let's just get a good
[ __ ]
stuff I think he just messed up Steve no
I don't no no no no you'd be compensated
I know how it I I know how I know how it
works I I know how it works because I
because I you know I've I've been on the
other side of helping someone with this
negotiation so I know precisely how it
goes all right there would never be a
conversation about money it would be a
conversation about story yeah [ __ ]
talking with Stephen Amell [ __ ] okay
those are the questions those are my top
tier patrons I love you you make the
podcast work go to patreon.com inside of
you I really appreciate your support
I'll write you a message after you uh
you become a patron and uh top tiers get
their names wrote off at the every
episode Chris R uh has your uh this is
quick rapid fire you know this you know
the rules how has your battle been with
anxiety cannot wait for heal season two
anxiety gone
I didn't having I didn't have anxiety
problems I had with I had alcohol
withdrawal problems at that time in in
general any anything that was tied to
anxiety had to do with the withdrawal
from alcohol so when you came on you had
anxiety it had to do with alcohol had to
do with alcohol yeah you know the Sun
that what are the the Sunday scaries
were they people they get anxiety on
like a Monday after you know going out
and partying or something like that on
on the side oh yeah anything any anxiety
that I had
um you know I cut out a 95 of my
drinking over the past year and a bit
and any anxiety that I had was purely
related to withdrawal from alcohol
awesome
Sophie M how is life with two children
you said it but how is it it's good it's
it's it's it's it's it's a challenge
it's a challenge it's a challenge
there's there's not a lot of
two wakes up in the middle of night you
share that
so any uh I am
I am off from Midnight to 6 A.M
but he sleeps through the night already
super it goes as of feeding it around
bath at six feeding around 6 30 goes
down about 7 30.
wakes up about 6 37 at this point so
we're blessed from from that standpoint
but uh yeah no I I cast as the evenings
I do the everything else how many hours
of sleep do you get it per night on
average
seven and a half anymore is probably not
good
I don't need
I don't need more than seven to seven
and a half hours of restful sleep I also
like
uh
uh I've really started to like getting
up in the morning to a quiet house for
about an hour an hour and a half good
yeah Sarah g hi Stephen
you and your family are doing well
congrats on your baby boy question is if
you could relive shooting an episode of
Arrow one more time and experience it
for the first time again which episode
of bny pilot
first time in the suit David Nutter
Vancouver two weeks 10 million bucks
pilot uh Megan T huge fan when filming
do you prefer to be free uh be free
creativity of create creativity or be
directed with step-by-step for the scene
depends on the director depends on the
scene
we had a we had an interesting the the
process on Heels this year changed a
little bit where it we took us a couple
of episodes to discover that uh
that our our showrunner really really
really really really really wanted
everyone to be Word Perfect this year
which is which by the way is fine I
don't like that
it's not my favorite come on we're not
doing [ __ ] Shakespeare here
my problem was not a problem is a very
lowercase p sorry about that by the way
I would do it no it's it's fine it was
more that it was more that it it wasn't
communicated
uh it wasn't it wasn't communicated up
front that they wanted us to be
word perfect so I thought that we just
had a super anal retentive script
supervisor for a little bit and then I
realized it very very early on and I
went to our show writer and I went
you want us to be verbatim right he goes
I do
and I said okay it's fine just changes
your process a little bit so
um I'm always up for being directed
right uh to and to to better answer that
question I'm always up for being I'm
always up for being directed I think the
thing that I that I dislike is I like I
like freedom but freedom without Freedom
doesn't exist without just a still bit
like a Teensy bit of structure because
if there's no if there's no structure at
all then no one knows what the [ __ ] to
do right
gotcha Maya P again last question then
we're done if you could tag team with
any professional wrestler who would it
be
I've got that question yeah it could
have gone South could've gone really
pleasant too
any current professional wrestler any
any in the in in the top in the world of
of any time period Well I'm gonna go
Cody Rhodes my boy you you've already
worked with Cody Rhodes I tag teamed
against against Cody Rhodes against him
that's right yeah do you want to do it
again do you want to do something like
that again I do want to do it again I
need to make sure that I will be you
asked earlier if I would be upset
devastated or what have you if
if there wasn't a season three of heels
uh the thing that would really
that the thing that I would really
really really have a problem with is if
we didn't get a season three and I
didn't do everything that I could
promoting season two and I think that
everything that I can do will involve me
being back on
television doing some wrestling in some
way shape or form dude thanks for being
here it was awesome always awesome
he always has a lot to say he's always
got something he always has something
and I love that he comes to me never a
dull moment I mean he could probably go
anywhere else he'd probably go to a
podcast with bigger numbers or whatever
but he I appreciate that you know I have
you know a lot of certain celebrities
that you know
come to my podcast or at least you know
why you live close that's it thanks for
bringing that up uh thank you Stephen
Amell
um remember uh join patreon if you want
to support the podcast anything helps uh
patreon.com
inside of you
and all that jazz
and all that jazz
here are the top tiers
uh also I you know Bryce said
tell the benefits of being a patron when
you join patreon there's a lot there's
things things called tears so they have
a top tier that gets packages from you
every few months in a letter from me and
I pack them I box them it's personal uh
I don't have somebody you know I have
somebody helping me you know do things
but I pick the things and I write the
notes and um there's that there's
YouTube lives where you every month you
ask me questions there's
um
a q a there's there's just a lot of
things uh on the tears
um what else very every once in a while
we do a big top tier Patron Zoom we've
done that a couple times and uh it's
just part of a community so many people
become friends from this
um I know that
I love it and it really supports the
podcast
um look some people you know can't
afford I think you could be a patron for
a dollar can't you 50 cents I think
you'd still support the podcast if you
give a quarter price of a cup of coffee
50 cents it's way less than a cup of
coffee these days buddy but I just
appreciate it and uh look it wasn't for
the patrons I say it a million times
probably wouldn't be able to do this
podcast there's so many out there and
bigger celebrities than I am and uh the
thing that I like is you know people
always say that you get in it's not like
a celebrity talk it's like talking about
real stuff and you get into real stuff
and you know um and I appreciate that
I'm glad it's not like a typical
[ __ ] podcast you know and I have
Ryan here I'm here some Brian keeps me
in line most of the time I try actually
I didn't even try that hard you keep
yourself in line pretty well I don't
know I think you know sometimes when you
walk in and it's noon you see me in a
robe at my computer and you're like it's
noon dude give me that look I know that
I gotta step up I'm like all right get
it together Rosenbaum Ryan sees it he
give you that look
hey it's a friendly look it's just like
you're in a rope I I showered and I got
dressed and I drove here you always look
to you always look nice me oh you have
jeans on a sweater well I mean before I
you know when there was a time when I
wasn't coming in to record the podcast
but this is the time when I leave the
house so I have to I shower I shower and
I get dressed you're not Felice clean
unless you're
cessed fully clean
okay Patron shout outs these are the top
patrons in order of who joined first oh
boy Nancy D Leah s right now the ass
Stubby's going I thought I was first
Sarah V Sarah V you've been around
I mean you've been with us
for so long little Lisa you Kiko
Jill e Brian H C Brian H and some
concerts everyone once in a while Nico p
and son Zach Robert B Jason W I believe
that's Dreamweaver
uh Sophie in Australia Krista Keo she
made me a beautiful blanket for the
holidays Raj she visited me in
Pittsburgh I mean most these people I
mean I love seeing these people I know I
like knowing them I hope those that I
haven't met I will I'll meet in person
uh Joshua D Jennifer and Stacy L Jamal F
Janelle B Kimberly e Mike e l Don
Supremo I haven't heard from Danny in a
while 99 more Santiago when is that Lex
Luthor Buster sending me gonna get here
sending me a bust for Lex Luthor
yeah Chad W Leanne P she's been around a
while really supportive of the podcast
and Son spin the band it means a lot
because our band we don't have tons of
followers so when you guys listen and
come to the stages and uh you know get
the CDs or whatever it's it's just
awesome knowing someone is listening
Janine or I've got to see her she's a
sweetie Maya P of course Maya I just saw
you in Pittsburgh Maddie s Belinda and
Chris H Dave H David Hall Sheila G Brad
d Ray H oh man love her in Japan tab of
the T oh damn
Tom and Liliana a Talia M Betsy dinofrio
miss that woman Chad B Dan and big
Stevie W Angel amrianne and C Cory K Dev
Nexen Michelle a Jeremy C John B Brandy
D Camille s Joey M Eugene and Leah how's
that little guy doing Nikki G Corey
Patricia Heather L Jake B Megan T Mel s
Orlando C Caroline R Christine
I was in L and and sure Sarah asks Eric
Shane r m r Andrew M zaruichi 77 Andreas
and Oracle Karina and Amanda R gen B
Kevin e Stephanie K Lena 82 jorel Billy
s jam and Jay Leanne Jay ADHD Roxton
Luna R Cindy e Kate F Mike F and stone H
let me ask you a question Ryan before we
end this podcast
if you have a guest uh-huh
on the podcast and they're talking and
you hear that dry lip sound like
and you know people are going to be
annoyed when they hear it oh my God his
lips are dry do you a just let it go
because you don't embarrass the person
you say hey take a drink of water I
could hear your lips
um
I think you should probably tell them
would I personally I'd I would probably
not I know your podcast would fail right
probably but I think
it's the kind of thing to do yeah and
you can be nice about it uh guys this is
the first episode back for uh a new
season of talk fill
um you know I hope we keep going we do
kind of one year at a time and uh I love
doing it it's fun
um
yeah thanks for listening thanks for
listening thanks for being thanks for
allowing me to be inside of all of you
um much love healthy and happy New Year
let's do this I am Michael Rosenbaum
from the Hollywood Hills in California I
am Ryan here too you sir a little way to
the camera we love you guys uh most
importantly Ryan hmm uh be good to
yourselves be good to yourselves all
right I'll see you next week
[Music]